concerts and entertainment all coming
back to life and
so are the valuable fundraising events
that help local organizations who serve
southern nevada residents
fall into fashion at opportunity village
is one of those events that
had to bow out during the pandemic but
it's back and the ov
models are ready to strut their stuff
like never before
[Music]
strutting the catwalk like a high
fashion supermodel is a dream come true
for these men and women
of opportunity village the spotlight is
not shining on their disabilities
only their possibilities their
personalities
just shine through when they walk that
stage
and to educate people on how wonderful
that these models are and that they
represent
the population that's being served by
opportunity village
and to give them a little bit more to
look at than just the magical forest or
the santa run
but to actually see the people that are
benefiting from all of those fundraisers
melinda brown leads a group of
volunteers called the ov
angels which organized the annual fall
into fashion event
it has become a favorite of the
organization that serves and empowers
people with learning and physical
disabilities
the saturday fun starts with champagne
and shopping for jewelry and crafts
made by ov artists themselves there's a
silent auction and raffle with lots of
prizes
and a lunch buffet the eight chosen
models help design their outfits
and all of the money raised goes to the
pride program
which serves those who need
round-the-clock care and special
equipment
like melinda's daughter sarah she is
a girly girl and she loves to get
dressed up if she had her way she would
wear a different princess outfit to
opportunity village every day and
she loves to go to dances and she loves
to just get all dressed up and
you know do the things that young women
her age
like to do she's 32 years old now we
have this wonderful picture of her
last year just with her hand up over her
head
and just shaking her shaking her hips
just like
just like anybody else that's fantastic
that's wonderful volunteer first
responders escort the ov models
and will get special recognition this
year with the event falling on 9 11.
the is on september 11th it's 11 30 a.m
you can get tickets to ovs fall into
fashion
at the link on your screen and of course
we'll have that on our website
8newsnow.com
individual tickets are 65 or you can
save a little money get a group of
friends and get a table of eight for
500. that's the move
and it all goes to the madi peck
endowment fund which funds the
uh pride program and as i said there in
the story it's for those who
are are more disabled who need special
equipment who need round-the-clock care
and it's a special program for those
individuals and uh
you you get a bidding paddle and when
the models come out if you raise your
paddle
you can you can donate more money and
make a bid
and so the models are very amped up and
the more they strut around and the more
they perform on the runway
a lot of people will put their paddles
up and and give more money have you been
to this thing i have not have you been
i have not been to this one it's eight
years and going yeah
yeah it's a wonderful event they do
there and it's it's i i've been there
before as well we all have been over
there
to see the the folks who are taking part
in these events hamming it up for the
crowd
they are fired up it's good stuff so
sure looking forward to seeing that
coming up absolutely i'll be the emcee
i'm happy to do that this year it's
really going to be working on i look
forward to it
ladies love to come and shop because
there are hats and jewelry
and just it's champagne and a brunch it
might be fun
it might be fun i think it's going to be
a guaranteed